it's all change at the top of the French
government the country's new Prime
Minister has just been named as Jacques
Tex he was responsible for coordinating
France's reopening strategy after its
coronavirus locked down earlier the
previous prime minister it wofully
handed in his government's resignation
to President Emmanuel macron Philippe's
decision to stand down has paved the way
for a reshuffle which had been widely
expected president Macomb had promised
to chart a new course for the last two
years of his term that will focus on
efforts to relaunch the French economy
now let's go straight to Paris and bring
it in EDW correspondent Lisa Lewis for
more on this Lisa who's the new man what
do we know about John castex he's a 55
year old senior administration of
official a public servant who's well
known in public servant circles he's
been the mayor of a small town in
southern France for a few years he was
also working at the Elysee under Nicolas
Sarkozy the former conservative
president and as you said he's been part
of the team with that now former prime
minister I'd like Philippe to put in
place
Frances strategy to come out of the
lockdown here after the coronavirus
crisis after the peak of the coronavirus
crisis he's known to be hardworking and
very efficient very well known in
circles of public servants but quite
unknown to the French public okay a bit
of a technic right it seems does his
appointment as Prime Minister mark the
beginning of a change of policy then in
France well it does mark the beginning
of a change of strategy by in Manama
coin used to have this widely popular
prime minister I'd love Philippe
Philippe who is as seen in a positive
way by more than half of the French now
he's got someone who basically no one
knows so he's not John cast X is
unlikely trait to take up part of the
limelight and among McCaw wants to
reinvent himself indeed in the coming
two years ahead of the 2022 presidential
elections that is unlikely to happen
through
Prime Minister it's more likely that in
my McCall will take up more space he
said that he would invest lots of money
into the economy to get it back on track
also invest money to help young people
find new jobs after the Kovach 19 crisis
and also help elderly people you know
who are dependent and do a reform in
that area but he also said in an
interview with regional newspapers this
morning that if he wouldn't change
completely course actually he wants to
stick to his major reforms such as the
pension reform the very controversial
pension reform against which French had
been demonstrating for months before the
kovat lockdown happened and it looks
like a magma cone wants to give a fresh
impetus to his time in power to give him
a chance to get reelected in 2022 but
without changing cos completely it were
Filipe wasn't the only one to step down
the whole government resigned why was
that necessary well that's not
completely extraordinary he also
happened under a man Marcos predecessor
the socialist Francois or Londa it's it
is a sign again that in my macro is
trying to reinvent himself his present
presidency his image to show that to the
French that he will now do something new
and that they should trust him again so
that he has a chance of winning at the
presidential election again in 2022
he's a Lewisohn Paris thank you
you